yeah welcome to this VM playing as oh
she i am from not guessing Egypt ok
english defence with an only f5 yeah
this is quite a decent set up against
the English Defence white can also
ignore this and just plain 92 first
doesn't need to recapture and no you did
recapture okay yeah I need to take ok
let's try to can use this yeah this is
not hanging gathers slope strange why
would you misplace the Queen on h6 bit
weird ok let's tag on on f2k knight c6
Bishop g5 I can take be too
hmm I can take you for if I take you
four words what is so what is he doing
then
okay let's let's take it and see what
you are what you have in mind it goes
Bishop g5 I can take but then it can
castle short after Bishop g5 however I
can also play Queen fa it may be it may
be better intending to exchange Queens
and if you move the Queen back to h4 I
take f3 and I don't really see what else
you should play instead of okay this one
if I take can I take f-22 looks looks a
bit strange but maybe I can not really
but it's just develop and maybe I should
have checked on before hmm maybe I
should have checked on before could
could maybe this was a good idea
possible possible okay what I want to do
is it's let's get rid of them off the
Queen's I wanna pawn already and he has
no good way to avoid the Queen trade
let's just keep it keep it simple oh why
not why not on g7 that's a good good
square attacking me too it's not easy to
defend this even
I completely forgot that I cannot move
the night wow this was unnecessary
you
well this gets far more difficult now
they're necessary far more difficult
yeah from a straight win to head to what
I don't know what and gas still be to a
saying take c6 I can take b2 and go to
deform something like that
I was hoping that this is actually a
misplaced rook maybe a maybe is this is
a wrong judgment ideas be sure to g6
basically trapping the Roku
some way to to make progress yeah and he
always has c5 yeah I don't know
I was thinking about just taking on you
three so it's interesting
we'll get six only 25 preventer Brooke
f8 made be 54 so the idea try to to get
a passport Gras effect yeah it's
probably a draw but with them with the
best pole I can I can try
I'm not so sure is it a draw hmm I'm not
quite sure why is giving me the
foursquare potentially I for it's just a
bad move now I'm I can just enter the
position
is just a win i get i get the jeep on
and then then my check on his ass the
winner yeah f4 is really bad move it's
completely pointless I mean you can you
can just stay put here and it's not easy
at all for me to to make any progress I
can try i can use the beep on but i
think it still should be it wrong also
considering that this is the wrong of
the wrong part i mean it's a dark square
Bishop the way it was played you also of
course should have tried that one so
that I only have the h-bond but it's a
win anyway right yeah it's a win anyway
you never get to get to the strong drawn
position alright thanks for watching